you give me an example of just showing
whether it's someone waking up in the
morning and they have back pain oh yeah
I think I'm saying yes of course
Breaking Bad
who's this horrible guy he wanted
something you know killing is his is his
brother-in-law
we don't mind seeing die but but he
winds up ruining his family entirely
Jessie every when we first see Walter
White and who actually first see him in
his underwear in the desert but when we
first see him at home waking up he's
waking up in this awful little bedroom
with a terrible nightstand from from
Ikea he's got this crappy little
exercise he gets up on an exercise she's
broken after about 10 seconds some of
those step things and then the camera
pans to the wall and we see on the wall
in 1985 Walter White was in line for a
Nobel Prize and then we go back to him
he said and and and he's he's dead he's
been some things murdered him what is it
well we find out much later what it is
that he was betrayed he was he was a
betrayed by it by his partner by his
love but he is and then he goes and he
slumps out and he's sitting at this
breakfast table and it's his 50th
birthday and he gets soy bacon for his
birthday and that his wife goes eat it
you'll like it and then his son comes
out and says well the water heaters not
working well just you got to get up
early with a person shower why can't we
buy a new water heater right well cuz
Walters a loser right everything about
Walter shows us that he's been horribly
wounded by something so what we're
rooting for is for Walter to get better
and someone Walter becomes a badass I
don't know about you but I'm on his side
I know he's killing innocent people I
don't care what forget him give Stan
kill that guy so that is a terrible part
of the human soul baby but it's the
device by which we make a character
sympathetic is to show their wounds
because as human beings we're not going
to be interested in good-looking perfect
people who have Lincoln making a lot of
money
they're great and everything they do who
gives a we want to see people that
we can identify with because that's not
us we've got problems right I've got
problems right I want to see my problems
and somebody else with problems dealing
with problems okay
and you can say well you know a show
like like Riverdale doesn't do that but
they do and there's fantasy shows
absolutely fantasy shows where where
that's not the case but most of the time
you do want to see a wound that's what
likability really means oh they're like
me they're screwed up they don't have it
all together which I did maybe they'll
get it together right and then that
means that I'll get it together uh-huh
yeah how did they get it together right
but mostly it's just together like me
you know they're not perfect they're not
you know they they're like me well
you've been using an acronym for a
little bit and what's funny is driving
over I was looking over the notes and I
think that David had said off camera
that BMOC stands for big man on campus
and the basketball world which I was not
privy to I did not know that but if
we're writing what what what is your
take a beginning middle obstacle climax
that's what that stands for why I found
this out years ago analyzing all movies
that it was equally mc-squared moment
for me there are four crescendos in a
movie where the hero is asked to change
and asked to learn the theme of the
movie and asked to learn how to heal all
the things I talk about the big things I
talk about healing learning the theme
stopping bleeding all that there's four
times in a movie story inevitably that
that happens at a crescendo
it's a 30-page of sin 60 pages in 90
pages in and about a hundred and eight
pages in those I call the beginning
middle of to climax the BMOC
right now that's a structure that is in
every great movie practically you've
ever seen
it's not in a Godard movie okay if
you're writing a French Wave movie I'm
sorry I won't be able to help you that's
just a French guy peeing in an alley for
two hours and that's great right I love
those movies but but in a Hollywood film
that
structure is invariably in the story and
if it's not there's usually something
missing it'll be superseded someday but
that's what's operating now know that
BMOC operates in everything every movie
Dunkirk
in Deadpool everything but now in
Deadpool let's just take an example in
Dead Poets a great movie again I'm big
on wounds right what's our wound in the
Deadpool the guy well he's wounded cuz
he's ugly he becomes extremely
disfigured by a chemical bath right and
because of his wound I'm ugly he can't
face his girl
he doesn't feel lovable so the big
crescendos the BMOC points in that movie
are is he gonna have the the balls or
the courage to believe that his his girl
will love him even though he's ugly okay
so we'd he's got to learn in there to
heal his wound does I'm lovable his
wound is I'm not lovable right and and
that's a woman we can all identify with
why a lot of a thing we're not lovable
so he's his journey in Deadpool the
crescendos of the movie are are you
going to realize you're lovable the
answer for for him is yes no no no yes
yes no no yes because after he gets
chemically doused he's too ugly and it
takes in most of the movie to get to
where he can take his mask off that's
the climax right that's a final he takes
the mask off now I use Deadpool I could
use a more highfalutin movie but I want
people to understand these these this
pattern the BMOC works in every movie
now you can say wow that's great clear
that's a tool a tie so what the tool
will help you write your movie you got
to figure out what your theme is you got
to figure out what your characters wound
is and you have to got how they're gonna
be healing it that's it those are the
three things so the BMOC does that now
the interesting thing is a few years ago
I freaked out and nearly lost my
because I thought okay god movies are
they're gonna be over television is
oh my god I'm a movie guy I don't know
what to do so I slowly sort of
tentatively said okay well this work
does this work but one way meant that
works okay that works is the BMOC work
well the BMOC turns out to work in
television as well so this tool works in
drama and in comedy and TV as well
because why because what we want to see
in a story is a hero learning to heal
and even if he doesn't heal completely
because he doesn't in TV he's still
gonna go on a journey towards healing a
little bit the critical difference
between film and television this and TV
the hero doesn't heal but he heals a
little bit and then at the end he gets
ripped open again so every week he's
gonna heal a little bit and then get
ripped open again every week 150 times
but the BMOC works at the exact same
places in a television hour than it does
in a movie there's just an extra in
because there's an extra act so let's
take a four hour television
structure the BMOC it's be in MOC The OC
the obstacle point is the point when it
looks like the he was going to lose and
in a movie this is right at the 90 page
point let's take a movie already know
Star Wars Luke gets to the planet the
last rebel planet
Darth has followed him there with a
homing beacon that he's got a Death Star
he's gonna blow up the whole damn thing
there's nothing Luke can do about it
there's just a little few star fighters
and he's got a Death Star that's it the
movies over and then of course what
happens r2d2 says hey I stole the plans
of the Death Star there's a little hole
you can fill it a missile in if you
really get close and Luke you can the
only one get that missile in that hole
if you use the force not your computer
and so the obstacle point is all is lost
and the climax is Luke learns the theme
of the story Luke will you use the Force
to rescue the princess and save the
Republic he puts his computer away all
the other star fighters used if they
couldn't get the missile in he puts his
computer where he's
learned he hears obi-wan say Luke use
the Force not the computer and he puts
the missile in the hole climax so the
obstacle point is always lost and the
climax is Luke you did it in Breaking
Bad the obstacle point is he's making
meth in the desert jesse comes back out
with crazy 8 and the other criminal
they're gonna kill him both waltzin is
underwear
he has no defense he's gonna get shot
and killed but then he says teach you
I'll teach you how to cook I'll teach
you how to cook my recipe and they goes
really yes and they go in the RV and
Walter throw his poison into the thing
whoosh and the climax says he kills them
both and becomes the mass murder he's
gonna be for the next hundred and fifty
episodes so that's the climax so the O
and the C point and I'm not explaining
this well I'm sorry but it's in my
lecture online it's a complex little
tool but it works so great it's like a
little engine that works any television
structure you want just like it did in
film so what did I learn when I started
learning about television everything I
learned in movies works every element
that I learned about in movies works in
television the structures just a little
more complicated that's all
you